WENT SO FAR AS TO CALL THE POLL
WORKERS, QUOTE, SECRET AGENTS.
>> DON'T BE FEARFUL, GUYS.
>> CNN OBTAINED THIS RECORDING
OF A WAYNE COUNTY GOP TRAINING
SESSION OVER ZOOM THE NIGHT
BEFORE THE MICHIGAN PRIMARY LAST
MONTH.
>> SO YOU'RE ALL REALLY
UNDERCOVER AGENTS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> IT'S EXTRA TRAINING, PARTISAN
TRAINING.
NOT JUST FOR VOLUNTEERS
OBSERVING ELECTIONS, BUT
INCLUDING THE ACTUAL PAID
ELECTION WORKERS WHO WILL CHECK
IN VOTERS, HAND OUT BALLOTS,
EVEN HELP IN THE COUNTING, WHICH
IS WHY WHAT THEY ARE BEING TOLD
IS ALARMING.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF BAD STUFF
THAT'S HAPPENING IN THE UPCOMING
ELECTION SO WE HAVE TO KEEP OUR
HEADSEN A SWIVEL AND START
DOCUMENTING IRREGULARITIES.
>> THE POLL WORKERS ARE HIRED BY
CLERKS, AND THEY ARE TOLD THEY
MAY NEED TO BREAK THE RULES TO
UNCOVER FRAUD.
>> THEY WERE TOLD BY THEIR
TRAINERS THEY COULD NOT HAVE
THEIR PHONES WITH THEM.
>> I WOULD SAY MAYBE JUST HIDE
IT.
AND MAYBE HIDE A SMALL PAD AND A
SMALL PEN.
YOU NEED TO TAKE ACCURATE NOTES.
>> IF WE'RE OBSERVED WITH A PEN
AND A PIECE OF PAPER WRITING ON
ANYTHING, THEY SAID THEY WOULD
ASK US -- THAT THEY WOULD REMOVE
US.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE TO DO IT
SECRETLY.
>> THIS TRAINING FOR THE PRIMARY
WAS JUST PRACTICE FOR THE
UPCOMING MIDTERMS, ACCORDING TO
KONSTANTINO, AND IT'S WHO'S
DOING THE TEACHER.
>> WE THINK A LOT OF THE MONKEY
BUSINESS HAPPENING IS HAPPENING
AT THE VOTE AGGREGATION
LOCATION.
>> THAT'S ELECTION DENIER WHO
CO-LED THIS TRAINING SESSION.
HE'S A FORMER STATE SENATOR WHO
WROTE A BOOK CALLED "THE 2020
COUP" AND HAS A BLOG FILLED WITH
DEBUNKED CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT VOTING MACHINES.
HE SPREADS SO MUCH
DISINFORMATION ABOUT THE 2020
ELECTION, HE GOT THIS CEASE AND
DESIST LETTER FROM DOMINION, THE
VOTING MACHINE COMPANY, SAYING
YOU ARE KNOWINGLY SOWING DISCORD
IN OUR DEMOCRACY, ALL THE WHILE
SOLICITING EXORBITANT AMOUNTS OF
MONEY.
HE'S APPEARED ON STEVE BANNON'S
SHOW AND WITH THE MY PILLOW GUY,
MIKE LINDELL.
>> WE DID SEE EVIDENCE IT WAS
CONNECTED TO THE INTERNET.
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE ANY
VOTING MACHINES WERE CONNECTED
TO THE INTERNET IN THE 2020
ELECTION, BUT HE'S STILL ASKING
REPUBLICAN POLL WORKERS TO
CHECK.
>> THERE'S A LITTLE ICON ON THE
BOTTOM RIGHT-HAND CORNER.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THESE MACHINES
ARE INDEED CONNECTED TO THE
INTERNET.
>> HE REFUSED TO SPEAK TO CNN,
BUT THE OTHER LEADER OF THE
TRAINING, SHERYL KONSTANTINO,
DID.
>> YOU'RE TRAINING THESE PEOPLE
TO BE UNDERCOVER SPIES.
THAT'S THE WORDS YOU WERE USING.
I'M WONDERING WHY.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IF YOU
REMEMBER IN THE ELECTION TWO
YEARS AGO, THERE WERE SO MANY
PROBLEMS.
>> WITH ELECTION STAFFING, SHE
SAID, WITH WHO COUNTED BALLOTS,
BUT SHE'S AN ELECTION DENIER
TOO.
SHE FILED A BASELESS LAWSUIT IN
DETROIT ALLEGING ELECTION FRAUD
IN 2020.
IT WAS THROWN OUT.
WHY DID SHE TELL ELECTION
WORKERS TO ACT LIKE SPIES?
>> TO KIND OF REFRAME IT AND
MAKE IT MORE FUN AND
INTERESTING.
I SAID JUST, YOU KNOW, INSTEAD
OF CAUSING A BUNCH OF SCENES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT, JUST WRITE IT
DOWN, KIND OF BE LIKE SPIES AND
LET ME KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> WHILE MICHIGAN'S PRIMARY
ELECTION WENT SMOOTHLY --
>> I DID NOTHING WRONG.
>> A POLL CHALLENGER AFFILIATED
WITH COLBECK AND HIS TRAINING
WAS THROWN OUT OF DETROIT'S
BALLOT COUNTING CENTER FOR
REPEATEDLY GETTING TOO CLOSE TO
WORKERS.
>> I TOLD THEM THAT THEY WERE
BREAKING THE LAW.
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MICHIGAN
IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE NATION.
ATTEMPTS ARE UNDER WAY TO MAKE
SURE THE ULTRA MAGA RUN THE
ELECTION PROCESS, FROM POLL
WORKERS ALL THE WAY UP TO
CANDIDATES FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE AND ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TRUMP ATTORNEY MITCHELL HAS LED
SEMINARS IN EIGHT SWING STATES
UNDER THE PRESUMPTION DEMOCRATS
CHEAT.
CNN CAUGHT UP WITH HER IN
WISCONSIN.
>> WE'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S ANOTHER SET OF EYES
GOING ON WATCHING THE BALLOTS,
WATCHING THE VOTING, WATCHING
THE PROCESS, KNOWING WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE ELECTION
OFFICES.
>> THESE TRAINING SESSIONS ARE
PLANNED CHAOS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING
RADICALIZED.
>> JEFF USED TO LEAD THE
MICHIGAN REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> THEY THINK THEY'RE SAVING
DEMOCRACY FROM THE CANNIBAL
SOCIALISTS WHERE IN FACT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS ERODING THE
PUBLIC'S FAITH IN ELECTIONS.
>> JAKE, MICHIGAN SECRETARY OF
STATE SAYS HER STATE IS READY
FOR ANY ISSUES THAT MAY ARISE
FROM THESE PARTISAN TRAINING
SESSIONS, AND THE CLERKS WHO RUN
THE ELECTIONS CAN REMOVE ANYONE
VIOLATING THE RULES.
BUT ON A MORE POSITIVE NOTE, AND
THERE IS ONE HERE, THOSE SAME
CLERKS ARE TELLING ME THAT MOST
OF THE DISTRUST OF THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM IS BORN OF IGNORANCE, AS
WE HAVE SEEN SO MANY TIMES.
AND WHEN THESE SUSPICIOUS
WORKERS ACTUALLY GET IN THERE,
GET THEIR FEET WET, AND SEE HOW
ELECTIONS ARE RUN, ACCORDING TO
THE CLERKS, THEY GENERALLY
BECOME BELIEVERS IN THE SYSTEM.
LET'S HOPE SO.
>> LET'S HOPE SO.
DREW GRIFFIN, THANKS SO MUCH.
I WANT TO BRING IN THE MINNESOTA
SECRETARY OF STATE, DEMOCRAT
STEVE SIMON.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO HEARING
THESE REPUBLICAN INDIVIDUALS
SUGGESTING THAT POLL WORKERS
BREAK THE RULES FOR PRESUMABLY
THE UPCOMING MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
>> IT IS DEEPLY, DEEPY
DISTURBING.
I THINK CNN'S DOING A PUBLIC
SERVICE JUST WARNING ALL OF US
WHO DO ELECTIONS TO BE ON THE
LOOKOUT FOR THIS.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH ANY
POLITICAL PARTY OR POLITICAL
MOVEMENT ORGANIZING FOLKS TO
SHOW UP TO BE ELECTION JUDGES.
IN MINNESOTA, WE NIDE 30,000
PEOPLE TO STEP UP AND DO THAT,
BUT THE RULE IS YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE YOUR POLITICS AT THE DOOR.
AND IN MINNESOTA AND IN MOST
STATES, WE MAKE OUR ELECTION
JUDGES OR POLL WORKERS LITERALLY
SWEAR AN OATH TO BE FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL.
IF YOU CAN DO THAT, IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT YOUR POLITICS ARE.
IF YOU CAN'T, IF YOU THROW SAND
IN THE GEARS, IF YOU NRTD FEAR,
INTERRUPT, DISTURB, THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
>> WE SHOULD MAKE IT CLEAR,
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
PARTISAN POLL WATCHERS, WHICH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
REGULARLY ENGAGE IN, AND THAT
HELPS BUILD CONFIDENCE IN THE
PROCESS, AND PAID POLL WORKERS
WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
NONPARTISAN WHILE DOING THEIR
JOBS.
SO YOU'RE THE TOP ELECTION
OFFICIAL IN MINNESOTA, WHICH IS
REGULARLY A BATTLEGROUND STATE.
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS BEING THE
LONG-TERM EFFECT OF THIS TYPE OF
TRAINING ON THE ABILITY FOR
STATES TO CONDUCT FAIR
ELECTIONS?
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THE
PUBLIC'S FAITH IN ELECTIONS IS
GOING TO KEEP BEING ERODED?
>> I AM CONCERNED THAT THIS IS
ONE EXAMPLE AMONG MANY IN THE
PAST AND UNFORTUNATELY PROBABLY
SEVERAL IN THE FUTURE WHERE
PEOPLE TRY TO BLUR THE LINE YOU
MENTIONED.
POLL CHALLENGERS, AS WE CALL
THEM IN MINNESOTA, SOMETIMES
OBSERVERS, THAT'S OKAY.
IN MINNESOTA, EVERY PARTY GETS
ONE, NOT 20, NOT 2, 1 DESIGNATED
IN WRITING, TO BE EYES AND EARS
OF A POLITICAL PARTY.
BUT THAT'S A VERY DIFFERENT ROLE
THAN THE PERSON HANDING OUT
BALLOTS, GREETING FOLKS, MAKING
SURE THEY CAN GET REGISTERED AT
THE POLLS.
WHEN YOU BLUR THOSE LINES AND
TELL PEOPLE TO GO IN AND DISRUPT
AND EVEN IN YOUR CLIP, TO BREAK
THE LAW, THAT IS A BRIDGE WAY
TOO FAR.
THAT IS AGAINST THE LAW IN
MINNESOTA, AND I SUSPECT IN MOST
STATES.
BUT IT'S DISTURBING THAT PEOPLE
WOULD TRY TO BLUR THAT LINE AND
SEND PEOPLE IN KNOWING THAT THEY
WILL BE AT LEAST ATTEMPTING TO
BREAK THE LAW.
>> YOU HEARD DREW GRIFFIN REPORT
THAN PRO-TRUMP ATTORNEY CLETA
MITCHELL, HAS LED SOME OF THESE
MAGA ELECTION TRAININGS IN EIGHT
DIFFERENT BATTLEGROUND STATES
FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T REMEMBER,
CLETA MITCHELL WAS ONE OF THE
FIGURES ON THE PHONE IN JANUARY
2021 WITH YOUR REPUBLICAN
COUNTERPART IN GEORGIA,
SECRETARY OF STATE BRAD
RAFFENSPERGER, PUSHING
RAFFENSPERGER TO FIND,
QUOTE/UNQUOTE, FIND ENOUGH VOTES
FOR TRUMP TO WIN THE STATE, EVEN
IF THEY DIDN'T ACTUALLY EXIST,
THOSE VOTES.
YOU'RE THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
DEMOCRATIC ASSOCIATION OF
SECRETARIES OF STATE.
WHAT ARE YOU SPECIFICALLY DOING
TO PROTECT THE SANKITARY OF THE
VOTING BOOTH FROM THE KIND OF
INTERFERENCE WE KEEP HEARING
ABOUT AND SAW IN THE LAST
ELECTION AHEAD OF THE NOVEMBER
MIDTERMS?
>> WELL, IN MINNESOTA, IT'S
ABOUT PUTTING PEOPLE ON NOTICE
ABOUT JUST THE KIND OF TACTICS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AGAIN, I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR, ANY
POLITICAL PARTY, POLITICAL
MOVEMENT, ABSOLUTELY.
SIGN PEOPLE UP TO BE POLL
WORKERS.
MAKE SURE THEY UPHOLD THEIR OATH
AND UPHOLD THE LAW.
ONE IS PUTTING PEOPLE ON NOTICE
ABOUT THAT.
THE OTHER, THOUGH, WHICH YOU GOT
TO A COUPLE MINUTES AGO, IS
TRANSPARENCY AND SUNLIGHT ARE
OUR FRIEND.
OVERTIME, I'M NAUPT SAYING IN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS, BUT OVER
TIME WE CAN HAVE AN IMPACT BY
ACQUAINTING PEOPLE WITH THE
ELECTION SYSTEM AS IT REALLY IS.
WHETHER IT'S MINNESOTA,
MICHIGAN, OR ANY OTHER STATE.
ONCE PEOPLE ARE EXPOSED TO THAT
AS ELECTION JUDGES OR ANY OTHER
CAPACITY, THEY INVARIABLY COME
AWAY IMPRESSED AND WITH A TON
MORE CONFIDENCE.
THEY SEE HOW HARD IT IS TO GET
AWAY WITH MISCONDUCT.
THEY SEE ALL THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES.
THEY SEE THE LAYERS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
GUARANTEES OF TRUSTWORTHINESS.
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING WE HAVE
TO GET OUT THE WORD FOR GOING
FORWARD.
THIS IS A LONG-TERM PROJECT.
I'M DISCOURAGED BY YOUR REPORT,
AND WHAT IT SAYS ABOUT ATTEMPTS,
ORGANIZED ATTEMPTS, TO CORRODE
WELL EARNED TRUST IN THE SYSTEM,
BUT I'M CONFIDENT THAT OVER TIME
WE CAN MAKE SURE THE FEVER
BREAKS IF WE WORK AT IT.
>> PLUS, OF COURSE, THERE ARE
THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT
VOTING MACHINES AND FRAUD THAT
DOESN'T EXIST.
YOU'RE UP FOR RE-ELECTION THIS
YEAR.
YOUR REPUBLICAN APONE WANT, HE'S
CALLED THE 2020 ELECTION RIGGED.
HE HAS LIKENED CHANGING THE
RULES AROUND VOTING IN 2020 TO
THE SEPTEMBER 11th TERRORIST
ATTACKS.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THESE
KINDS OF ALLEGATIONS?
>> WELL, THEY'RE FOOLISH.
THEY'RE IRRESPONSIBLE, AND
THEY'RE ULTIMATELY REALLY
DANGEROUS.
WE CAN HAVE ALL THE POLICY
DIRJS
DIFFERENCES WE WANT.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
BUT IF WE CAN'T AGREE ON THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL FACTS OF WHAT
THE SYSTEM IS, FORGET ABOUT WHAT
IT OUGHT TO BE AND WE CAN HAVE
THOSE DEBATES, THEN WE'RE IN
TROUBLE.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOT JUST BY MY
OPPONENT BUT OTHERS RUNNING
ACROSS THE STATES, AND NATIONAL
POLITICAL LEADERS FANNING THESE
FLAMES IS AN ATTEMPT TO SPREAD
DISINFORMATION.
YOU MENTIONED CLETA MITCHELL.
I WOULD CALL HER A SUPERSPREADER
OF DISINFORM